EÉRIC DUHAIME, chef,
PaParti conservateur du Québec
- - On a toujours le pif puis
leles intuitions de M. Legault,
mamais on n'a jamais de chiffre.
CoCombien de gens n'ont pas eu
lala COVID parce qu'il a imposé
unun couvre-feu pendant le temps
dedes Fêtes? Combien de gens n't
papas la COVID a aujourd'hui pae
ququ'il était en train de foutre
leles restaurants en faillite en
leles fermant pour une 4e fois?
CoCombien de gens ont pas la COD
auau Québec parce qu'on a fermé
leles cinémas pendant les semais
leles plus payantes de l'année?
SiSi les mesures sanitaires
ététaient si efficaces que ça,
onon aurait le meilleur bilan,
papas le pire.
A Aujourd'hui, le chef du
PaParti conservateur du Québec,
EÉric Duhaime, dont les appuis
sosont en hausse, selon un sonde
LéLéger publié ce matin,
réréclame la levée de toutes
leles mesures sanitaire.
J'J'en discute avec lui.
EÉric Duhaime, bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Cette demande de lever les
rerestrictions et les mesures
sasanitaires, est-ce que est
reresponsable à ce moment-ci, au
momoment où le système ciment
écécroule?
- - Le problème Québec, notre
sysystème de santé beaucoup plus
quque le virus. Je aujourd'hui,
c'c'est exactement ce que le
RoRoyaume-Uni vient d'annoncer n
pepeu plus tôt dans la journéeùu
ilils vont haver justement les
memesures sanitaires, le masquee
sesera plus obligatoire, le
papasseport vaccinal va
didisparaître ou les gens vont
popouvoir reprendre une vie
nonormale, ou le télétravail n't
plplus encouragé, un paquet d'Ét
dede nos frontières aussi, on a
jujuste à regarder les matchs de
lala NFL pour voir 80 000
pepersonnes entassées, alors
ququ'ils ont un taux de
vavaccination de forme que le
nnôtre. On a 280 personnes aux
sosoins intensifs, on met 1
mimilliard de dollars par semaie
dadans le système de santé et on
n'n'est pas capable de soigner 0
pepersonnes aux 300 personnes. e
prproblème est le système de saé
dede toute évidence
- - vous évoquez l'exemple de
BoBoris Johnson, qui est en tran
dede sauver sa carrière politiq,
paparce qu'il a participé à des
rarassemblements illégaux. Ce qe
vovous ne dîtes pas dans votre
réréponse, c'est que c'est le ps
lele plus endeuillé, il y a une
gegestion chaotique de la pandée
etet que cette annonce
d'd'aujourd'hui s'accompagne d'e
cacampagne de vaccination massi.
- - On est déjà l'endroit le pls
vavacciné, on les Québécois ont
étété très docile et obéissant,n
s's'est fait le plus vacciné, et
mamalgré ça, le gouvernement
cocontinu à nous imposer des
memesures les plus liberticides,
onon ne respecte pas les droitse
lala personne que c'est ici quea
dédémocratie est en poste depuis
dedeux ans. On est 47 000 nouvex
momots Parti conservateur,
cocommence à y avoir une grognet
M.M. Legault, cinq chiffres dans
leles sondages quand ça descend,
ilil faudra qu'il soit le code e
lala population. Les restaurates
ququi viennent à peine d'ouvrir
leleurs portes illégalement, pls
dede cohésion sociale.
- - Revenons aux mesures
sasanitaires, c'est le masque, a
didistanciation sociale de se
lalaver les mains, donc on a
rarajouté aussi la distanciation
mamais le moins de contact
popossible, c'est dans cet esprt
ququ'on veut freiner l'Omicron,
ququi est extrêmement
trtransmissible, donc ces mesurs
quque vous remettez en question,
mmême le masque?
- - Vous pouvez parler du
papasseport vaccinal...
onon va y aller graduellement.
- - Ma question est le masque.
- - Ce que j'ai dit aujourd'hui,
jeje vais vous répéter, il fauty
alaller graduellement évidemmen,
mamais les premières maisons qui
leleur partirent que c'est de
pepermettre aux gens de pouvoir
sosocialiser. C'est important qe
leles gens puissent recevoir ler
fafamille, leurs amis à souper,
c'c'est important de rouvrir les
rerestaurants, c'est important
d'd'éliminer le passeport vaccil
paparce que c'est un outil
didiscriminatoire et on a aucune
évévidence scientifique ça un
ququelconque impact.
- - Sur quelle science vous
apappuyez-vous?
- - Je appuie sur la science que
sisi ça fonctionnait, le passept
vavaccinal, M. Legault aurait
afaffirmé les endroits où les gs
momontrent leur passeport
vavaccinal. On ne pas fermait ls
enendroits où il y a juste du
momonde qui rentre avec un
papasseport.
- - Certains réclament à
l'l'économie davantage de
popossibilités déposées le
papasseport vaccinal, je pense à
lala fédération des chambres de
cocommerce. On veut justement...
- - j'ai vu les quincailleries r
lele contraire aussi.
- - D'autres demandent le
papasseport vaccinal pour
prprotéger. Je reviens à mon pot
dede départ. Sur quelle science
vovous appuyez-vous pour dire qe
leles mesures sanitaires ne sont
papas efficaces? Je vous donne
l'l'exemple, on vous a vu hier
avavec Anne Casabonne, pas de
mamasque avant hier, on peut vor
lala photo. Quel message renvoi?
CeCe qu'on peut éviter la
didistanciation que l'on peut ne
papas porter le masque?
- - Vous me demandez c'est
popourquoi la science derrière .
C'C'est quoi la science
dederrière.., laissait-moi juste
rérépondre... la science derrièe
leles employés de la SAQ et la
SQSQDC où on oblige le passeport
vavaccinal. Vous avez le droit e
trtravailler même si vous n'êtes
papas vacciné mais vous ne pouvz
papas acheter une bouteille de
vivin. Il y a des incohérences.
LeLes Québécois en ont soupé de
ceces incohérences il y a de pls
enen plus de gens, vos
tétéléspectateurs comprennent ç.
- - Je vais vous soumettre le
sosondage de ce matin de léger,
vovous canalisez ce mécontentemt
susur les mesures sanitaires. On
vava et venait au vaccin et au
papasseport vaccinal. Ce matin,
d'd'abord, M. Legault est très
popopulaire, le taux de
sasatisfaction et à 60 %.
6767 % appuient les mesures pour
lala SQDC et la SAQ. Pour
l'l'vaccination obligatoire, ça
n'n'est pas encore que 65 %,
ququ'une taxe santé, 61 %. Couv-
fefeu, plusieurs considéraient e
lala science est en rapport avec
sasa 49 %. L'idée est d'empêcher
leles contacts. Donc, ce que vos
ddîtes que c'est faux quand vous
ddîtes que c'est généralisé et
ququ'il y a une dictature de la
mamajorité, ce sondage montre
ququ'il y a un appui.
- - Condamnez les sondages, vous
reregardez d'abord et avant tout
l'l'intendance. On remarque une
dédégringolade de plus en plus e
l'l'appui à M. Legault.
SaSatisfaction a baissé de 15 %.
- - Il est encore la meilleure u
papays.
- - Il est rendu deuxième. Il a
IlIl est derrière le l'Colombie-
BrBritannique depuis quelques
sesemaines. Tout ça est en
trtrain... on arrive à une
écécoeurantite aiguë, les
QuQuébécois on est très bon, mas
àà un moment donné, on s'égare.
JeJe n'ai pas beaucoup de gens i
onont beaucoup apprécié le 31
dédécembre, se faire rappeler
ququ'on avait couvre-feu. Beaucp
dede gens étaient furieux contre
M.M. Legault.
- - Vous avez déclaré que au fo,
onon a plus de fans au Québec,
c'c'est comme si c'était au cene
dede votre programme politique,
esest-ce que ces descend comme
prprogramme politique qu'on a ps
dede fun au Québec.
- - En tout respect, les gens, l
y y a des choses qui sont
esessentielles dans la vie, le
gogouvernement et les
fofonctionnaires ont décidé qu'l
y y avait des gens pour qui le
reremploi était essentiel et
d'd'autreses qui sont pas
esessentiels, ils se sont faits
didire que leur job n'est pas
esessentiel. Ils se sont faits
didire ça des policiers qui n'ot
jajamais perdu un sou, ils ont u
dedes laissez-passer pour ne pas
rerespecter le couvre-feu, à qui
onon n'a pas demandé le passepot
popour rentrer à l'Assemblée
nanationale. C'est facile de die
auaux gens : faites ce qu'on dit
n'n'est pas ce qu'on fait. À un
momoment donné, il faut que les
élélus comprennent au Québec le
momouvement qui est en train de
nanaître. La division de la
sosociété québécoise, c'est pas
ququelque chose de positif.
IlIl faut rassembler son peuple,
papas le diviser.
- - Est-ce que vous ne nourrissz
papas... pourquoi ne mettez-vous
papas autant d'énergie à plaider
popour l'vaccination, c'est la
sosolution. Il y a un bout de
chchemin à faire parce que les x
nonon-vaccinés occupent encore
5050 % des lits aux soins
inintensifs et ils sont à risque
popour eux-mêmes, pour les autr.
AlAlors pourquoi ne pas déployer
auautant d'énergie à plaider por
enenvoyer les gens se faire
vavacciner que de demander
seseulement la levée des mesures
sasanitaires?
- - Je suis un démocrate et pour
momoi, les droits fondamentaux t
ciciviques que c'est fondamenta.
J'J'ai j'avais pensé vive dans n
ététat où depuis deux ans, on a
mimit la démocratie sur pause. e
nene croyais jamais vivre dans e
rerefuserait à des gens d'entrer
dadans des endroits et des
cocommerces. À chaque fois, dans
l'l'histoire de l'humanité, qu'n
a a discriminé de cette façon,
vovous le savez, ça ne s'est
jajamais défini. La discriminatn
sysystémique, la division
alalimentée par un chef d'État,
c'c'est inacceptable.
- - Vous nous parlez comme si on
ététait en Chine.
JeJe vous demandais de réagir
apaprès ces extraits.
- - O je poste pour ceux qui
OnOn nous le.c 29 sec
DrDre CÉCILE TREMBLAY,
mimicrobio.-infectiologue, CHUM
- - Pour ceux qui pensent que
c'c'est faux. Il faut vraiment
s's'enlever ça de l'idée et
OmOmicron peut causer une malade
auaussi grave que Delta.
CÇa va être particulièrement
vrvrai chez les non-vaccinés.
DrDr HOANG DUONG,
prprés., Ass. méd. interne QC
- - Je pense que tout le monde
pepeut faire sa part. Quand
vovous vous faites vacciner,
ququand vous limitez vos contac,
vovous diminuez le poids qui
esest exercé sur le réseau.
DiDirectement, vous sauvez des
vivies. Rien de moins que ça.
- - Vous vous affichez avec une
cacandidate qui est anti
vavaccination. Elle a dit que
c'c'était une cochonnerie.
- - C'était une satire inspirée
d'd'un monologue qu'elle avait
fafait dans un film de Pierre
FaFalardeau donne à titre de
cocomédienne. Ce qu'on a fait ls
dede la conférence de presse,
c'c'est qu'elle a mis sur pause
pependant quelques jours ces
réréseaux sociaux parce qu'on a
crcréé une nouvelle page je pene
ququ'on est rendu à 18 000
pepersonnes, parce qu'on voulait
cacanaliser toutes les personnes
coconservatrices qui voulaient
s's'intéresser à Madame Casabone
d'd'aller sur le nouveau réseau
sosocial qu'elle a créé.
- - Est-ce que les vacciner?
- - Vous savez comme moi qu'ella
chchoisi de ne pas répondre à
cecette question, j'appuie dans
seses décisions. J'ai parlé de a
quque j'ai dit mon statut
vavaccinal, comme vous savez, ms
jeje respecte la liberté de chox
etet pour moi c'est de
l'l'information confidentielle.
GuGuillaume Lemay-Thivierge
popoursuit les Mediapart qu'ils
onont révélé son statut vaccinal
quque si je conçois que c'est ue
ininformation confidentielle.
- - J'ai deux questions en même
tetemps, ça se rejoint. Pourquoi
vovous plaidez pas pour une
vavaccination encore pour la
trtroisième, pour aller plus lo,
popourquoi on atteigne encore ps
hahaut. Qui sont vos conseillers
scscientifiques?
- - Vous avez trois questions.
VoVous me parlez... est-ce qu'on
esest un rassemblant de
cocomplotiste? Dans la région de
QuQuébec, c'est une des régions
leles plus vaccinés de toute la
prprovince actuellement.
LeLe Parti conservateur du Québc
cocompte sur l'appui de 22 % de
l'l'électorat alors qu'il y a 6%
dedes non-vaccinés. À Montréal,a
rérégion l'moins vacciné au
QuQuébec, il y a des quartiersùu
4040 % des gens qui ne sont pas
adadéquatement vaccinés. On està
2 2 % dans les intentions de vo.
IlIl faut faire attention aux
amamalgames, ce serait dangereux
dadans ce cas-ci parce qu'il n'a
papas de corrélation, il y a mêe
plplus que les trois quarts de s
sysympathisants qui sont
dodoublement vaccinés. Pour ce i
esest de la troisième dose, je
susuis contre le passeport
vavaccinal à trois doses, contre
lele fait qu'on ajoute une
trtroisième dose et la raison et
quque j'ai mon propre gars. J'ai
atattrapé la COVID dans le temps
dedes Fêtes et mon propre médecn
m'm'a dit d'attendre trois mois
avavant de me faire vacciner que
leles anticorps actuels sont
susupérieurs aux vaccins et même
l'l'Dre Quach était sur vos onds
lala semaine dernière pour dire
ququ'il y a aucun avantage et
auaucun bénéfice et que c'était
ininutile de le faire mais le
gogouvernement pose parce qu'il
veveut rentrer son passeport
vavaccinal avant trois mois et
popour des raisons politiques, n
esest en train d'aller contre ce
quque les scientifiques nous
rerecommandent, trouvez-vous ça
nonormal? Est-ce que ça fait de
momoi quelqu'un qui est anti
vavaccination parce que j'ai mix
écécouté la science que la
popolitique parce que j'ai mieux
écécouté un médecin qu'un
popoliticien?
MaMais conseillers scientifique,
jeje vous les révélerai pas pare
quque je vais leur parler avant
s's'ils veulent vous parler mais
çaça va me faire plaisir de leur
dedemander de l'vous appeler si
vovous voulez jaser.
- - Vous voulez de la transparee
dede la part du gouvernement.
- - Je ne commencerai pas à donr
leleur nom sur les ornements de
leleur parler.
- - Et Anne Casabonne, c'est une
cacandidate crédible?
- - Aujourd'hui, il y a certains
cocommentateurs de certains
adadversaires politiques trouve
ququ'elle n'est pas crédible, ms
ilil leur est tous pris dans les
papartis politiques parce que Ae
CaCasabonne et mes a adoré de
totous, et c'est déjà fait
apapprocher et je peux vous dire
quque c'est une candidature qui
esest important pour nous et
l'l'élection d'un Marie-Victorin
esest très importante, c'est la
prpremière que les gens pourront
sese prononcer sur la gestion de
crcrise de François Legault, Ane
CaCasabonne va travailler très
fofort.
- - Le vaccin est important pour
sosortir de cette pandémie, on
popourrait demander à Madame
CaCasabonne de renoncer au fait
ququ'elle dit que ce soit privée
etet qu'elle p plaide elle aussi
enenvers faveur de vaccins.
- - Madame Casabonne a le droit.
auau Québec, on a toujours eu le
lala liberté de pouvoir s'injecr
ququelque chose dans notre corp.
OnOn dit qu'il faut que ce soit
lilibre et éclairé. Présentemen,
onon n'est pas là, et si le
gogouvernement veut aller au bot
dede sa logique, comment ça se
fafait qu'il n'a pas mit la
vavaccination obligatoire?
- - On ne peut pas reprocher de
rerespecter le choix des gens.
- - À un moment donné, il faut
rerespecter, si on respecte la
liliberté des gens et qu'on impe
àà la vaccination obligatoire,
rerespectons la jusqu'au bout.
- - Je vous citais Dany Turcott,
ququi a mis une déclaration
nonouveau de 2010 que vous l'avz
vuvu, les artistes peuvent être
dadangereux quand il se pour des
scscientifiques et influencent e
pupublic.
- - On pourra parler longtemps,
momoi aussi je suis très fier et
jeje suis très fié de l'entrevue
coconviens d'avoir